o las reacciones son muy muy ruidosas en
la plaza de rabín de tel aviv se han
juntado o se están juntando miles de
personas para celebrar muchas banderas
de israel muchas banderas que dicen la
palabra ley en hebreo que significa vete
son las banderas que se estuvieron
ondeando aquí durante todo este último
año en las manifestaciones en contra del
actual gobierno y parece que aquí
empieza ahora la gran fiesta que se
inauguró hace muy poquito tiempo en el
parlamento el último
en hablar fue el actual ministro de
defensa
benny gantz que también es actual es del
ex ministro perdón fue ministro
comprende tania hoy va a seguir siéndolo
en el gobierno de ménez lápiz y le
agradeció en servicio a que tenía un le
dijo gracias a partir de ahora nosotros
vamos a retomarlo y vamos a retomar lo
de manera discreta el liderazgo también
contra irán y también para mejorar las
condiciones de los israelíes pero con
otro talante y otro estilo
el mundo está aquí congratulándose y
celebrando
el ayuntamiento de ayala bien que es en
la playa en la que me encuentro han
encendido una banda
que está reservada para las ocasiones
así de especiales